[Music]  i assume you're ready for action this  kitten's always ready for action  darling you're even more gorgeous in  person  multiple countries have warrants out for  your arrest i'm popular  this little kitten sauntered into the  lair of the wrong big cat  i thought this was supposed to be a  party  my kind of party  is built to leviathan crime syndicate  it's now richer than many countries you  help us buff leviathan your warrants  disappear  catwoman  must die i did not sign up for this did  you sign up for this um  you really have to think about that  prepare to get your ass kicked  don't make me fight dirty  [Music]  a cat always yeah yeah lands on her feet  i've heard the saying don't you ever get  tired of that  darling i love your costume hold on to  that one love or i might just steal him  away  [Music]  you